when Michigan congressman Justin Amash
announced he was leaving the Republican
Party to become an independent he didn't
just say goodbye to the GOP he opened up
a whole new set of possibilities in
American politics it's gotten worse and
worse and and I think this was the term
that really broke it for me in choosing
principle over party the 39 year old son
of a Palestinian refugee has become the
spokesman for all Americans who believe
in limited government since taking
office in 2011 Amash has been an
outspoken critic of out-of-control
government spending state surveillance
and unauthorized Wars he believes that
Donald Trump engaged an impeachable
behavior but he's primarily motivated by
his belief that Congress is no longer
doing its job of writing laws that the
executive branch implements the founders
envisioned Congress as a deliberative
body in which outcomes are discovered he
wrote in the Washington Post
we are fast approaching the point
however where Congress exists is little
more than a formality to legitimize
outcomes dictated by the president the
Speaker of the House and the Senate
Majority Leader Amash doesn't believe
the system can be reformed from with it
I don't think there is anyone in there
who can change the system it's pretty
rigid it's top-down it comes down from
leadership to the bottom and over the
years it's gotten more rigid so it's
more difficult now to actually change
the process than it was even a few years
ago this is something Amash has been
consistent on for his entire time in
Congress he's called that Nancy Pelosi
for straight jacketing the way
legislation is introduced debated and
voted on in the house
while leveling exactly the same
criticism against her Republican
predecessors the speaker has not been
protecting the institution so you need a
speaker in there who is an
institutionalist who cares about the
institution first who is not a partisan
let the house work its will let
legislation come to the floor let
Republicans and Democrats and others
offer their amendments and let's have
votes on all sorts of things substantive
things not just post offices like they
do now modern politics is trapped in a
partisan death spiral he says but there
is a way out if Congress will actually
do its job there is a desire for
something else I think the vast majority
of Americans are for that something else
and what you have right now are two
parties that are relatively small and
weak and actually the reason they are so
partisan right now is because they are
small and weak when you get parties that
are that small that week you start to
have the fringe your elements of each
party rise up and and make the noise
libertarian views are actually the
mainstream views if you go around my
district and talk to people most people
have generally libertarian views now
would they call themselves libertarians
would they say hey I'm a libertarian not
necessarily but they have a set of
principles that are American principles
embedded in this culture in this society
and they are fairly libertarian
principles and I think we need to be
able to present that to them and find
some way to present an alternative going
forward I think as these parties get
smaller and smaller there will be more
independents maybe a third party has a
chance but I I think the future I see is
one where there are no strong parties
and more independent candidates we don't
really need the parties anymore Amash
says he'll run for Congress as an
independent and he's confident that he
can retain a seat but he also hasn't
ruled out running for president either
possibly as a libertarian whether that
happens Justin Amash has already stirred
things up by doing what he believes in
rather than what's convenient for
partisan purposes for that alone he
deserves our attention and commands our
respect
[Music]
you